علمنا الشهر الماضي أن
رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي جيروم باول قد تم
خداعه من خلال مكالمة وهمية من
المخادعين الروس في محادثة فيديو في وقت سابق من هذا
العام، ناقشت باولا السياسة العالمية
والاقتصاد مع شخص كان يعتقد أنه
الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي،
وتبين أن زيلينسكي كان من المؤيدين الروس
لبوتين.  الذين سبق لهم أن خدعوا
مسؤولين مؤثرين آخرين يُنظر إليهم على أنهم ماثيو تشانس،
حصلوا على فرصة للتحدث مع
المخادعين والتحقيق في الدافع
وراء حيلهم، ألقوا نظرة على
المخادعين سيئي السمعة المؤيدين للكرملين،
لكن الحرب الأوكرانية أعطتهم
تركيزًا جديدًا وضحايا جدد لخداعهم، انظروا
من هو  هناك سيدي الرئيس مثل جورج
دبليو بوش الذي اعتقد أنه كان يتحدث مع
الرئيس الأوكراني الذي من المفترض أنه
اتصل لمناقشة التحالف العسكري الغربي،
لقد أردت دائمًا أن أه تأخذ
أوكرانيا إلى الطبيعة وليس روسيا ولكن
أوكرانيا دائمًا كما أتذكر هذا
صحيح، كما شعرت  كانت أوكرانيا بحاجة إلى أن تكون عضوًا في
الاتحاد الأوروبي وفي حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو)،
أخبر مسؤول روسي لاحقًا
المخادعين أن ذلك كشف الحقيقة حول
طموحات الولايات المتحدة منذ فترة طويلة لإبعاد
روسيا عن أوكرانيا. كيف أعرف
أنك لا تخدعني عندما تتصل بي الآن
وتصل إلى  الحقيقة، ما يمكن
تركه غير معلن هو ما
أخبرني به المخادعون
أولاً، الأمر يتعلق بما يبدو عليه هذا الشخص
حقًا وكيف يتصرف رئيس دولة ما
في محادثة غير رسمية،
فنحن مهتمون بالحصول على إجابات أكثر صدقًا
مما قد نحصل عليه في
مقابلة عامة عادية:
أحد الانتقادات الموجهة
إليك هو أنك
تعلم دائمًا أنك متعاطف مع وجهة
نظر الكرملين، دعني أسألك بشكل مباشر هل
تعمل بناءً على طلب الكرملين
لفضح المسؤولين الأجانب أو المعارضين
للكرملين؟  قدرة السلطات الروسية
بشكل عام، من الخطأ القول
بأننا مؤيدون للكرملين، فنحن أكثر
مؤيدين لروسيا لأن هذا هو
بلدنا الذي نحبه ونشعر بالقلق عليك،
وتقول إننا نتصل فقط بأولئك الذين هم
ضد الكرملين ولكن ها هي تلك
روسيا ببساطة ليس لديها الكثير من الأصدقاء
الآن
[موسيقى]
رافعة من ناحية أخرى لديها الكثير
خاصة في واشنطن وتتظاهر بأنها
فلاديمير زيلينسكي
الرئيس الأوكراني حصل على نتائج المخادعين الروس،
نقول فقط إنه لشرف عظيم
أن أتحدث إليك مع الشخصيات المؤثرة
مثل رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الأمريكي
الذي اعتقد أن
الرئيس الحقيقي زيلينسكي يستجوبه بشأن
الاقتصاد العالمي ويقترح على بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
السماح لأوكرانيا بطباعة دولاراتها الأمريكية
لتمويل الحرب مع روسيا. إذا كان بإمكانك أن
تقدم لي مطبعة سأفعل  كن
سعيدًا حقًا لأن
لدينا واحدًا من هؤلاء ولكن اه لكننا
نحتفظ به في الطابق السفلي، حسنًا،
لكنك مرة أخرى، أعلم أنك
ستعتمد على الكثير من المساعدة
من الغرب والولايات المتحدة
وهذا  ليس فقط المسؤولين الأمريكيين الذين يتعرضون
للمزاح، بل نود أن نواصل
البرنامج النووي من أجل حماية
أنفسنا من ذلك. وقد
تفاجأ وزير دفاع الرئيس الروسي عندما طرح من كان
يعتقد أنه رئيس
وزراء أوكرانيا فكرة
السلاح النووي، وأعتقد أن روسيا ستفعل ذلك أكثر من كونها محايدة.
أكره هذا
بالتأكيد، نحن لا، نحن نعرف
هذا، أدانت الحكومة البريطانية هذه
المزحة باعتبارها مباشرة من
قواعد اللعبة في الكرملين، لماذا لم تقم بمزاح
نوع من الأشخاص البارزين في روسيا مثل
فلاديمير بوتين مثل رئيس
جمهورية الشيشان رمضان خاديروف  مثل
براغوسي رئيس فاغنر، لماذا لا
تتدخل في دعوة هؤلاء الأشخاص لكشف
الحقيقة عنهم، فقد يؤدي ذلك إلى حدوث
كارثة في بلدنا لأن
المكالمات يمكن أن تُحدث ضررًا في
سياستنا الداخلية
وخاصة في الوضع الحالي ولكنك
لست قلقًا بشأن المخاطر والمخاطر الناجمة عن
القيام بما تفعله في
المجتمعات الأخرى، فكر في المخاطر التي
يمكن أن
تضر مجتمعنا بالطبع
ولكن الحقيقة هي أن الروس الأقوياء حقًا
لن يتسامحوا أبدًا مع التعرض
للمزاح بهذه الطريقة
ولن تتمكن لكزس ببساطة من ذلك  أفلت من
خداع الكرملين الذي قام باتخاذ إجراءات
صارمة ضد النسب،
في حين أن أعداء روسيا في الغرب
وخاصة في الولايات المتحدة يعتبرون
لعبة عادلة، حسنًا، نعم، شكرًا لك، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك،
فرصة سي إن إن لندن